you
[Music]
all right thank you yeah thank you all
for having me here giving me the chance
to share something about what I've been
working on so we see children in the
world can learn to walk and then with
experience they learn to walk faster
more stable II and in robotics
you can program a robot to walk but no
matter how much this robot walks back
and forth along the field it's not going
to get quicker or more stable so in my
research I've shown how actually robots
can learn from experience and with
experience they can learn to become even
faster and more stable when walking in
fact faster than anyone had been able to
program this particular robot before the
the general picture of my research
though is that I want computers and
robots to be able to learn how to take
actions to achieve goals so not
necessarily just focused on robotics but
potentially applicable to many more
areas what this means concretely is that
the computer or robot what I'll refer to
as the agent should be able to learn a
policy which will map any given state of
the world to an action to allow it to
reach a goal so this is the same as the
goal of the field of reinforcement
learning and I think probably many of
you all here are familiar with the many
attention-grabbing success stories that
reinforcement learning has been putting
out that have come out of reinforcement
learning the past few years so
superhuman performance at video games
superhuman performance at the game of Go
simulated robots learning to play soccer
and then also some industrial industrial
success stories such as web marketing
some work done
here at Microsoft has contributed to
some of that control of data centers or
control of home thermostat systems but
with all of these successes if you look
a bit closer of course what we can see
is that these learning systems are not
very efficient
so this Atari video game result involved
the agent taking 50 million actions
before it had a good policy in the game
of Go playing 21 21 straight days of
self play millions and millions of games
and is one more example these simulated
robots
a year and a half of compute time to
learn all the skills to play soccer so
if we want this reinforcement learning
to be applied to real-world robotics or
healthcare or more data scarce settings
there's still a lot of work to be done
and I think the question that many
people in both industry and academia are
asking is can reinforcement learning be
data efficient enough for real-world
applications so this is the question
which is motivated in my research as
well but I think before answering this
question there's actually another
question that we should be asking which
is just how can an agent learn to
predict the effects of its actions
meaning like if I do this then this is
the outcome to expect
whereas if instead I did that this is
what I should expect um so I'm gonna
talk about a couple of different ways
that we've looked at this prediction
question in my research the first one is
just going to be given a fixed policy a
way of doing a task what is the expected
performance that we'll see when we run
that if we were to use that policy to
accomplish the task and the other thing
I'm going to talk about is how an agent
can predict how its actions will change
the underlying state of the world so I'm
going to start with this question of how
we evaluate the performance of just a
fixed behavior but before jumping into
that I'm going to briefly introduce the
the reinforcement learning setting if
you're already familiar with this this
is just like a way for me to kind of get
some of my assumptions that I bring to
the table out in the open so we're all
on the same page so the reinforcement
learning world has several components
how its usually defines I'm going to
introduce these with an example that
I'll use throughout the first part of
the talk of an autonomous vehicle
learning to drive to reach a destination
so the first thing you have to define is
your state space for the autonomous
vehicle this might be its position in
the world or where other cars are
relative to it this is all the
information that it needs to make
decisions the vehicle is available to it
actions which influence the underlying
state of the world such as like steering
the wheel braking or accelerating and
then there's a notion of reward which
captures what it is to
be successful at the task so maybe it
just gets a small small reward for
reaching its destination and if it gets
in an accident it could receive a very
large negative penalty and then finally
it's the policy is what defines the
behavior of the agent so for any state
in the world the policy tells the agent
how it should take an action to achieve
its goal interaction in this setting
happens sequentially it's not just about
choosing one action but the agent will
begin in one state it will take an
action receive a reward depending on how
good that action was in the particular
state and then it will transition to a
new state and this process will repeat
and so one assumption I typically I
commonly make in my work is that this
interaction will get one for some fixed
number of steps and then the agent can
like go back to its initial state and
try the task again and this whole
sequence of interaction is is referred
to as a trajectory through state action
reward space now in reinforcement
learning the problem that most people
think about is that of policy
improvement we're given some specific
tasks let's find the policy which
maximizes the amount of reward we can
obtain but there's another very
important reinforcement learning problem
and that is just policy evaluation where
we are given a fixed policy we're not
going to try to improve it but we just
want to know how much reward should I
expect to receive if I ran this policy
and this is I would argue that this is a
more important problem than that of
policy improvement first of all it's
necessary it's usually a necessary first
step if you want to learn a good policy
you should first be able to evaluate
your current policy and second when you
want to deploy systems in the real world
you really want to know how well is this
going to do before I like put it out
there and have it like interacting you
know with real people and real objects
so let me just go a bit more into depth
on the policy evaluation problem okay so
imagine this autonomous vehicle has one
of two outcomes that's going to see when
it drives and I'm definitely greatly
simplifying here of course in the real
world there's just like an infinite
different possibilities that this
vehicle could experience but let's just
say with very high probability it
reaches its destination and with very
low probability there's a safety driver
that has to intervene to prevent the car
from crashing and these outcomes we can
quantify with the amount the amount of
reward that the vehicle would receive
for them so reaching the destination is
like a small maybe a small positive
event the safety driver happening
intervene is a very strong negative
event so evaluating the policy is just a
matter of evaluating the expected value
of what the outcomes will be but where
this gets difficult in the reinforcement
learning setting is that these outcomes
aren't just like kind of one-shot things
but they're actually the they're
happening in a trajectory so we have
like a bunch of individual decisions
which all kind of combine together to
result in these outcomes and so these
probabilities are not themselves known
you can't just analytically compute what
is going to happen when you run your
policy so one setting where this is like
really important to consider how we can
do policy evaluation well actually sorry
just I'm getting ahead of myself I the
more formal notion of this instead of
moving away from this example is that
we're given a target policy which is
what we want to evaluate we're going to
assume that the target policy is a
distribution over actions given the
current state and what we want to know
is what is the expected total reward
that will be received along a trajectory
when we run this policy so why do we
care about this so imagine that like you
were an engineer at a self-driving car
company you've got a new policy that you
were considering pushing out to users
that was going to be controlling their
car so one thing that I mean I hope that
a self-driving car engineer would do in
this situation is they would before
pushing that out they would spend some
time testing the policy trying to get a
very accurate evaluation of what is
gonna happen when we push this policy
out to real users and then after this
testing phase there would be a
deployment phase where the policy would
actually go out in the real world and
during the deployment phase
you could expect that there's gonna be a
lot less safety mechanisms that are in
place if the policy does something
really bad so the testing time is where
policy evaluation is very necessary and
so how I imagine this would probably be
done is it would hire a very large
number of test drivers you'd give them
the pot a car running this policy they
would each go collect some trajectories
running the policy and report back with
how well the policy performed
quantifying this of course with the the
reward that was received and from this
information if you did this you could
get an estimate of how well the policy
was going to perform so this is a very
natural way to evaluate a policy but
what I would want to emphasize here is
that it's a very passive approach to
doing this you're just running the
policy and seeing what happens and I'm
gonna talk in a second about why that's
bad but first I just want to say this is
it so there's the general way of doing
this is what's known as Monte Carlo
evaluation in a reinforcement learning
setting repeatedly run the target policy
observe state action and reward
trajectories and then just average the
total reward seen across each trajectory
it's a really simple way of doing this
the the problem with doing it this way
is that there may be very rare outcomes
but that they have a very large impact
on what your estimate of your policies
value is going to be so for instance in
this case it's you're very rarely going
to see the safety driver have to
intervene and so you may miss that or
you may if you see it more frequently
than its true true probability you may
get in a very inaccurate estimate that
way so what this would look like is if
this showing on the x-axis here how much
data is collected and the y-axis what
your estimate would be with the blue
dashed line being the true value that
you're trying to estimate you might be
like you know overestimating your
policy's value and then when you get
this like a single rare incident your
values gonna kind of swing around and
it's not going to be until you've
collected a very large amount of data
that just by the law of large numbers
you would converge to getting a good
estimate of your policies value
so what would actually be better to do
in this setting is to take a more active
approach in how you collect data in
other words what we would want to do
here is we would want to increase the
probability that the safety driver needs
to intervene and if we did that we can
get a better quantification of the
impact of that event on our estimated
reward so if your I did say that policy
evaluation is somewhat motivated by like
applications of safety so I am now
advocating that we should increase the
probability of a very bad event so if
that sounds strange it is exactly
thinking about these kind of settings
where we can possibly put safety
mechanisms in place like here a safety
driver of being there to intervene so
that we can just get a very good
estimate of the policies value before
we're in a setting where there are no
controls and whatever happens is going
to happen and maybe cause you know cause
larger damages or something so if you
agree with me that being more active in
how we do policy evaluation increasing
the probability of these significant
negative events can be a good thing
there's still technical challenges which
remain to be able to do this so the
first of these technical challenges is
once we take a more active approach to
data collection where now we've shifted
the distribution of the outcomes that
we're going to see and because we've
shifted this distribution we can no
longer just average the rewards we
observe like we do in the passive
approach and then the second thing is
that because we're generating
trajectories you need a particular
policy to be able to to figure out how
to generate these significant rare
events so we need to know what is the
right data collection policy to be able
to explore so it's in this this second
technical challenge where my work has
made its contribution I'm going to first
talk a little bit about how we can
address this shifting data distribution
problem as this is necessary for the
second part but before continuing I
would like to just to get some
terminology straight when I say the
target policy I mean the policy we wish
to evaluate and when I say the behavior
policy I mean the policy that we're
going to you going to deploy to
collecting data so first with this first
issue how do we handle a shifting data
distribution when we change the policy
we've run it so imagine here that we're
now running a behavior policy which is
with 50% probability reach the
destination and with the other 50 cent
probability is going to cause the safety
driver to need to intervene so looking
at just the first outcome you can now
see that we're going to be reaching the
destination about half as often so a
very simple trick to correct for this is
to just multiply the outcome you see by
by around a factor of two and so this is
going to adjust for the fact that we're
now seeing we're not seeing that event
as much as we would have otherwise the
the general way of doing this is a
technique called important sampling and
it's a widely used technique I'm gonna
just briefly introduce it how it's used
in the RL setting we first repeatedly
run the behavior policy we then add up
all of the rewards received along each
trajectory just as we would in the
passive approach but then the key thing
here is that we re wait the reward
totals and you don't need to understand
exactly how this is done but basically
you're adding up the rewards as you
would in the the passive approach and
then multiplying by a relative
likelihood factor so this factor just
says if this outcome was more likely
under my target policy than the behavior
policy increase the weight on it if it
was less likely than let's decrease the
weight on it
once we've reweighed it it we can use
our observed data as if it had come from
our policy of interest so this makes
important sampling a very general
technique so that and it allows us to
address the first technical challenge
that we have here but we still don't
know what the right behavior policy is
and so that's what I'm going to talk
about next so myself and collaborators
looking at this problem we're asking the
question of what if we could only send
out a
you'll test driver in the setting that
we've described so we want to know we
have just uh yes it's bothering me so
suppose I think about the services
suppose there is a state where the
safety driver needs to be and I came out
roughly like reaching the state so in
terms of biking but a policy that gets
me to that state stage half the time and
your example for instance I can have
that goal in my mind but then coming up
with that policy seems roughly as hard
as solving the reinforcement learning
problem because I'm thinking about now
the ability to actually maximize this
toward which is getting to that state in
the MVP so so so so I guess that it
doesn't consider a party that I'm having
is that in order like is the problem of
trying to figure out good data
collection policy going to be basically
as hard as the reinforcement learning
problem or is it some is there some
structure that makes it easier yeah so
that's a great question first of all I
guess we're mainly focused on the
problem of policy evaluation here so I
think the you know the main question
we're asking is is just running that
policy using the target policy to
generate data is that more efficient
than adapting your policy and using that
to generate data and and so the answer
to skip ahead and bid in the talk is yes
it is more efficient to do that in terms
of the policy improvements question like
could you adapt things we're doing here
to that setting the answer again is yes
in principle you could there's some
there's some other challenges there as
well um I guess also just intuitively
what we are going to do is reinforcement
learning for finding a better policy the
data collection policy so we started
with this question of you know what if
we could just send out collect a single
trajectory could we get a perfect
evaluation of our poll
see with just a single sending out a
single test driver here so what this
this is again is the important sampling
estimate you don't need to follow all of
the math but we're basically saying with
a single trajectory this is what our
estimate would be and can we make this
exactly equal to the true value of the
policy so it turned out that that yes
you can do that however there's for some
while it's like theoretically you can
show it exist you can't actually
analytically compete what that best
policy is so we're gonna do what what
Alec is suggesting here and we're just
going to search we're gonna learn what a
better data collection policy is all
right so we write down an objective is
this done you know pretty standard in
machine learning you don't need to
follow all of the exactly what this is
but this is the mean squared error so we
basically look at the true value and an
hour estimate of that value given some
data and we want to know like how far
off are we from a squared error
perspective so you can't actually
estimate this quality because it it
depends on knowing the true value of the
policy and if you knew that you would
already be done with the evaluation
problem however what we showed in our
work is that you can estimate the
gradient of this objective with respect
to the behavior policy so this now gives
us a mechanism for adapting the behavior
policy towards one which will give us
more more accurate evaluation what this
looks like graphically is if you can
imagine the space of all possible
policies compressed along the x-axis
here we might start with the target
policy and if we use that to collect
data we could expect to have a certain
amount of error on average we then
estimate our gradient take a step along
that gradient and we end up at a
behavior policy which on average will
give us better data for policy
evaluation so if you're wondering how
this kind of connects to the talk of
increasing significant rare events it
turns out that the expression we derive
for the gradient tells us exactly how to
increase the probability of significant
rare events that might be encountered so
again you don't need to follow exactly
what this expression says but we
have one factor which says for these
actions increase their probability and
another factor which captures the
significant kind of how rare and
significant the particular event is and
overall this expression is saying if an
outcome is like very rare and has a big
impact that increase the probability of
seeing it so now we now have a mechanism
that allows us to learn a better
behavior policy so what this looks like
in this setting is we would collect a
small amount of data using the the
initial target policy anytime we we
discover an event which is going to have
a big impact on our estimate we increase
its probability and this can alter it
this can be repeated until you have a
very good data collection strategy and
really the key thing here is that you
can always like you can use all of the
data you're collecting as you learn to
also evaluate your policy so there's no
like wastefulness here this is like is
always going to improve over at our age
just passive way of collecting data the
generalist strategy is that we're going
to collect a small number of
trajectories with the target policy
locally improve the behavior policy and
then collect more trajectories and then
we can use all of the data to evaluate
it and optionally repeat this as many
times as desired and so with this
contribution we now know what the right
behavior policy is and we can use this
for more accurate policy evaluation so
I'm going to show briefly show some
empirical results these are on some
reinforcement learning benchmark
problems the y-axis is mean squared
error so lower is better and the x-axis
is how much data has been collected
so this is the Monte Carlo approach it
will get lower just because it's a
consistent estimator of the true value
but if you're simultaneously adapting
the behavior policy you can get better
more accuracy faster and these are it's
important to note that this on a log-log
scale so these our results are saying
between 30 and 70 percents more accurate
policy evaluation for any thick
amount of data that you could collect so
this is this wraps up the first part of
the talk just the main takeaways from
this is that first I would want to
emphasize that policy evaluation is
critical for safe and reliable
deployment of autonomous systems and
that I think active data collection is a
really important step to doing this
reliably in practice this work also
connects to a larger question of
counterfactual reasoning which is very
important for autonomous agents to have
and so my work has also made several
contributions in this these wider
questions one of our most recent results
has again been looking at this important
important sampling type methods which to
rely on computing a certain ratio so we
just presented some work showing that if
you take the the denominator of this
expression which is a the true
probability you were sampling data from
and replace it with its empirical
estimate that you can improve the
quality of important sampling so that's
some of the most recent work that we've
done on this topic for I guess I was
kind of curious in particular for the
car for example what would be like how
did I think about target policy like is
it a very good policy that's running a
lot of time in the near upright position
or is it a bad policy that's most of the
time like not getting there because that
is going to influence also the effect of
policy adaptation right so could you
yeah yeah so in that case that policy
was a partially optimized if somewhere
in between the two extremes we did have
looked so the amount of improvement you
get is going to be dependent on how much
variance is in the target policy return
so if you're really is like one like
extreme if you're running a target
policy that always sees the same thing
there's no advantage to doing this
we did always you're always going to see
some improvement if there is variance in
the target policies outcomes yeah so
actually I'm about to Anna I switch
gears and talk and talk more about like
a different part of the work that I've
done so if there's any questions on the
first part of the talk I could pause
here and take a couple male yes what
Steve what's the exact context in liquid
sea largest things the state dimension
that you actually expect yeah yeah so I
would say what we did the basic method
that we've implemented is essentially
the reinforced algorithm if you're
familiar with this for Policy gradient
methods so we didn't take this beyond
implementing this and like a kind of
simple reinforced approach in terms of
so we haven't really tried to scale it
up beyond those much but I would say you
know like so reinforce was like a policy
gradient method introduced in the early
90s there's been a lot of literature
showing how to scale that and you can do
a lot of those same techniques here so
yes
so those the ones I just showed I think
we're both horizon of two hundred time
steps yeah so I mean I guess I don't
know if you like your questions kind of
getting at some of like important
sampling and long horizon issues so I
think it's you know intuitively what's
happening is that we're we're learning a
policy which is gonna be kind of close
to the target policy but if there's a
way to get to these more extreme like
rare events it's going to increase the
probability of those actions so you
don't really have some of the same long
horizon issues that would normally
plague important sampling when your data
is just given to you from some arbitrary
behavior policy in fact here we're kind
of using like the variance of the
weights to counteract the variance of
the rid returns there so we didn't find
it like too hard in practice but yeah
like the one way this would is if you
were trying to like use that gradient
with a very poor estimate then that
wouldn't ya okay so now moving on to the
second part of the talk I also think
it's very important that agents are able
to predict how their actions influence
the underlying state of the world even
in a somewhat task agnostic way so what
I mean exactly by this you can connect
to model-based reinforcement learning
you know again going back to this
autonomous vehicle example we know that
if this vehicle was to accelerate from
standing still that it would begin
moving forward at a high velocity but to
an agent which is just beginning to
explore what its controls do to change
the state this isn't at all obvious so
concretely what I mean is that given any
state and an action the agent may choose
to take in it we want to know what would
be the predicted next state which is
going to result or possibly a
distribution over next States and I
think this is really key to scaling up
autonomy because if we could do this
perfectly like the policy evaluation
problem
we could do very data efficiently
instead of like collecting any test
trajectories we would just simulate all
the different outcomes and we could know
what any policy was going to do
similarly for policy improvement instead
of you know instead of generating real
experience we could learn from synthetic
or simulated experience in that way so
this part of the talk and the work we've
done here is very much motivated by the
gap we see in robotics between simulated
and real-world domains so in particular
this is a bit of experience that I have
working in the RoboCup 3d simulation
domain so what is I think interesting to
note here is just how smoothly the
robots move they're able to like you
know have these long kicks and move
quickly to the ball and the reason for
this is that you can apply reinforcement
learning in a domain like this and you
can heavily optimize all of the skills
that the robots use and so that you get
something which is much much better than
you could possibly hope to hand-tuned so
let's contrast this instead to what we
see on real robotics so this is from the
the RoboCup standard platform League
competition this is a robotics platform
that I've worked on throughout my time
as a PhD student and what you should
notice here is that the robots are
moving much slower they're kicking the
ball less far and less accurately and
there's no hope that you could really do
reinforcement learning directly on this
platform the robots would break actually
I guess I saw that you all have a now
robot on the third floor like just
trying to imagine applying a
reinforcement learning algorithm on it
you would need like a lot more a lot
more robots
so one hope is that we can just apply
the same learning that we're doing in
simulation and if we do it in simulation
then we can just put it on the physical
robot and it will all work out and we
won't need to actually do learning on
the robot so you have this setting where
you have an initial skill in simulation
that maybe doesn't isn't working that
well like a slow walk you can have the
same situation on the physical robot
where it's can it can wall
but maybe not as fast as you would like
apply a policy optimization algorithm in
simulation and what you get out is a
much faster walk at the end so then
maybe you're done you just take this
faster walk you put it on the physical
robot but unfortunately what you
typically see when you do that is that
the the policy finds something in the
simulated environment it over fits to it
and it tries to exploit that in
simulations get high reward and that
ends up failing in the physical world so
this is conjecture but like what it
seems to have happened in the video I
just showed is that the robot learns in
simulation it can walk very quickly by
just sliding its feet along the ground
and that doesn't work when you you have
a you're trying to walk on carpet like
this no so I'm going to show how we can
actually learn in simulation and get it
to transfer onto a physical robot and
introduce an algorithm for doing that
just to make this a bit more concrete
this is on the problem of robot learning
to walk so in the the general MVP setup
for this we have a state-space which is
the position and velocity of all the
robot's body parts there may be other
variables that we can't measure well the
action as the robot is going to choose
commands for each of its joints and
we're gonna reward it based on its
forward velocity that it's moving we
just care about moving in a straight
line and so we want to learn a policy
which tells us how to map the current
positions of the joints to commands
which are going to to make it walk fast
and so you can think of this in the
trajectory interaction is happening in a
loop where the agent is sending its
state to the policy and then the policy
is responding with an action so what we
want to now do is replace instead of
interacting with the physical robot
we're gonna interact with a simulated
version of the robot and learn from the
experience which is generated through
this loop them there's a general
methodology that we're gonna build on in
this part of the talk this is known as
grounded simulation learning so what
this is is that we assume we have a
policy we can execute in the real world
we can use
this policy to generate an initial set
of state action trajectories these
trajectories tell us what are the
effects of our actions on the state of
the world it gives us some data that we
can use to see how what the effects of
our actions are in the physical world we
didn't have a step of grounding the
simulator which means trying to make the
simulator give us trajectories similar
to what we observed in the physical
world once the simulator is grounded we
then apply reinforcement learning on it
and we can now expect our improved
policy to transfer back to the physical
robot because we had this grounding step
so returning to this problem I'm just
gonna make this a bit more concrete and
that what we want to do is we're going
to receive the current joint positions
of the robot which can be obtained from
its sensors and then the policy is going
to compute commands to sins there and so
when we talk about grounding the
simulation what this means from the
perspective of the policy is that
somewhere between sending those joint
commands to the simulation and getting
the new joint positions back we need to
change something so that the resulting
next joint positions it receives are
similar to what it would had it taken
the same commands in the real world and
so what we do in our work is we focus on
modifying the joint commands that the
robot sends to the simulation and by
doing this we're gonna call it we're
going to change the commands in a way
that makes the simulation give us back
joint positions like what we would have
seen in the physical world our approach
to doing this is that we augment the
simulation with what we call a grounding
module so when the robot sends its joint
commands they first get passed through a
grounding module which is going to
transform them and then into a modified
joint commands which is going to cause
the simulation to respond differently
than it would have had we just passed in
the original commands and we can
construct this grounding module through
two supervised learning problems so the
first step of this is that we're going
to observe our data and we're going to
learn how to predict what the real-world
effects would be based on the data that
we've observes so this is
a supervised learning problem and that
we have real-world data and you can chop
up this trajectory and get a set of
state action resulting next state at
least for some components of the of the
state features and so now we can just
train a model which tells us what is
going to be the real-world effect given
some actions we then need to just choose
an action which is going to cause the
same effect within the simulated
environment this is again can be done
with supervised learning we can collect
state action trajectories in simulation
and learn an inverse model which tells
us for any any transition what action
will cause it basically how to reproduce
the same effect in the simulated
environment so once we have this
grounding module we just incorporate
this into the reinforcement learning
loop here and from the perspective of a
policy it's going to look as if it was
interacting with an environment more
similar to the real world so I'm going
to discuss or show you a one application
of this to the task of robot walking
this is again learning on the now robot
that we use in the RoboCup competitions
we're going to do five minutes of
walking on this robot to collect the
real world experience and then we're
gonna apply a reinforcement learning
algorithm in simulation which requires
5,000 minutes of walking this would be a
completely intractable amount of
experience to collect on the physical
robot so this is the initial walk that
we start with I mean one one important
thing to note here is that this is this
is a walk engine which was developed for
the RoboCup competitions so there's a
lot of people throughout the world
trying to make this robot walk very fast
and this is as far as we know one of the
fastest walks that people had developed
for this robot so then we can put the
same walk directly in the simulation
this is it just kind of moving normally
along before we've done any grounding we
then applied the grounding algorithm
that I just suggested and you're gonna
see that the robot is going to begin
having a bit more trouble to walk it's
going to become a bit more unstable so
this is more like what we see when the
robot is walking in the physical world
then when it's walking in the simulation
environment
so once we then apply reinforcement
learning in the grounded simulation I'm
just doing a head of local policy
improvement on the policy we end up with
a wok which is 40% faster than than the
previous wok we started with so this is
now and as far as we know this is as
fast as anyone has gotten this robot to
go so to conclude this part of the talk
I again just want to emphasize I do
think that better action modeling is
like a very important step towards
long-term autonomous agents they were
able to do a lot of things in the in the
physical world and that in a lot of a
lot of real-world problems not just
robotics although certainly robotics is
a great example there are existing
domain simulations and that when these
simulations are available if we can
leverage them then it's going to go a
long way towards efficient reinforcement
learning there are of course also
environments where we don't have good
domain modeling and I think being able
to model a domain from scratch will also
be an important capability for
autonomous agents we've also done some
other work relating to how you can use
domain simulations to try to put
confidence intervals around the
performance of policies when you're
interested in things such as safety of
deploying a policy so this uh this wraps
up the part of the talk just there I
wanted to introduce some of the work
that I've done throughout my PhD before
concluding I'm just going to talk a
little bit about some of the the next
directions that I'm really interested in
exploring towards making reinforcement
learning data efficient enough for the
real world it's just a general comment
before getting into the specific
research directions I think that like
applying studying reinforcement learning
both from my more theoretical side or a
more algorithmic side as well as trying
to apply RL to problems where it just
falls flat on its face at the current
moment is a really important way of
doing research so one of the problems
that I plan on continuing working on
long term is this problem of robot
soccer it would be just really
intractable
right now to imagine learning this task
from scratch and so I think you know
this is a really good test bed for our
ell algorithms I think it's also really
important to work on multiple
application domains as you don't want to
necessarily produce technique at least
for me it's important to not just
produce algorithms which are only
specific to one test area so throughout
my PhD I've also been doing work on
traffic systems for autonomous vehicles
not necessarily just learning although
we are also looking at reinforcement
learning in this context and you know
moving forward I'm hoping that just you
know by working across different
application areas there's the potential
to develop algorithms which are
applicable to many different areas so in
terms of the the research directions
which I think are really promising to
explore for achieving this I think
looking at things such as state and
action abstractions is important for
scaling our ell understanding the
theoretical properties of methods that
we propose are important for having
reliable methods that we can trust in
practice and finally although I focus on
prediction I think that it's also
there's still like gonna be some steps
left from connecting prediction to
better policy improvement in terms of
state and action abstraction the the
basic idea here is you can think of that
like an agent has different levels at
which it can make decisions so for an
autonomous vehicle maybe it has an
action drive home which itself is
constituted by the different directional
turns that it has to make along the way
and each of those is made up of even
like very lower level controls beneath
the hood there so in RL reasoning at the
right level of temporal abstraction is
really is a big impact on how effective
your has a big impact on how effective
your algorithm can be if you're trying
to do if you're imagining trying to get
a vehicle to learn to drive home and
it's reasoning about this like very low
level of actions it's a very difficult
task compared to trying to reason at a
higher level of abstraction one problem
that I'm particularly interested in in
the space
is the ability to learn in very low
fidelity simulations so if you can
imagine in the game of soccer
you could be simulating at the level of
the robots actual the control of each of
its individual joint motors you could
also imagine simulating at the level of
just circles passing a ball around one
of these problems should be
significantly easier to learn in not
necessarily easy but easier to learn in
for things such as strategy and so you
know what is the right level of
trade-off what can you learn in a very
abstract representation that then and
can then be transferred back into the
the real task of interest I also think
with introducing abstraction you're
introducing approximation which can hurt
the guarantees that you can put on
methods I think it's it's really
important that we establish the
properties of methods that we're
developing so for instance statistical
properties such as just what is the
confidence that I can have in my
estimator or you know is a method
consistent meaning do I eventually get
the right answer with just enough data
so I think being able to like establish
methods like this are very important for
practitioners to be able to trust what
we do similarly it's also important to
be able to show that your methods are
scalable in the sense that if a
practitioner can't use it it doesn't
really matter how good the guarantees
are and also explainable so that you
know why why your predictions are what
they are
so finally most of what I do focuses on
prediction but I think there's still
even once we can do perfect prediction
in the space of modeling the effects of
actions or evaluating a fixed policy
they're still going to be some questions
open to connect this to efficient policy
improvement so I'm very interested in
looking at how do we search the space of
all possible policies defines the best
one for a task or once we learn on one
task how can we transfer what we learn
to a new task and so I think once we can
do and of all of this we're finally
going to be able to answer like the big
question and say that reinforcement
learning
can be data efficient enough for
real-world applications and so that's
what I'm looking forward to to
continuing on to do just before wrapping
up really quick of course there's a lot
of people we've contributed to this
research my adviser Peter stone has been
involved with all of this the first part
of the talk was done in collaboration
with Scott nickim at UT Austin and Phil
Thomas at UMass Amherst and then the
work I've done in the space of traffic
systems for autonomous vehicles that I
unfortunately couldn't spend time on
today has had like a very wide number of
collaborators as well so with that thank
you all for coming to the talk today and
giving me your attention um and I'd now
be happy to take more questions yeah
your trick is learning to grow right and
so you know with that right there you
basically memorize what the deltas are
and you keep on iterating on until you
come up with a policy that acts in the
real world like you would expect it yeah
and usually control people started doing
that because they they found that for
complicated any system modeling is just
hard right so they're like so if you
treat of learning control is nothing but
fancy words for I'm going to bypass
modeling I just learn a nominal model
and I'm going to learn the deltas now
there's this like you know one way it is
you learn an explicit model and find the
deltas in the model the residuals in the
model that matter in the spaces that you
care about the other way is I'm going to
just completely bypass modeling and
learn a good policy right
it's unless I missed some details it
seems you are taking the route of like
I'm going to bypass models right yeah
what kind of both and that we are we're
leveraging a simulation which itself is
a model of the world and so but within
within that simulation we are learning
in a model freeway where we are just
trying to directly get a good policy
there yeah right so
would you comment on what your thoughts
are like is there any advantage to see
in that specific domain let's say with
the now there's a superhot model by the
way and can we do approximate models and
then learn inject that habit in the
simulator and then learn the like you
know that does that you would need to
learn yeah I think I think it's a really
good question um so I think what we're
doing is actually somewhat similar to
that in that we are inherently and of
locally modifying the simulation so back
a few slides new is kind of showing this
process it's a loop
that's because it's like when you you
try to modify the simulation in a I
guess a data dependent way it's going to
be inherently bounds what that current
distribution of data you get from your
foreign policy is there's a um and so in
that sense we're you know correcting the
policy we're correcting the simulation
local to that particular policy
optimizing there but then we have to go
back to the real world and get more data
to continue that process so it's it
still has this like same at least like
high level like iterative learning
approach yeah so I'm curious what extent
you can correct the simulation just by
changing the action space like often a
lot of the errors in the simulation
could come from the physics that it's
you said they carpet no there's no
proper real life and you know just look
to your foot higher isn't it so I cover
that in all situations yeah that's a
good question to the I mean I guess like
some part of it is that we've so we've
done this I was talking some about
walking we've looked at some other tests
with the now robot and found that we can
correct things I could you know imagine
situations where construct correcting
the actions isn't sufficient to do it um
but it does so in like something even in
like we're not necess
you can even even though that is like a
physics parameter that could potentially
be adjusted as well you can't actually
like kind of use I think see things
getting captured and like how it changes
its emotions like if if the foot is
getting
on the carpet that in simulation like
instead of like letting your foot and
move as freely as it would then by
changing the actions you can make it
appear as if it was getting stuck more
on the carpet so I think like you can
like kind of capture some of these
things by just modifying the actions as
well I think there's definitely some
things that it wouldn't be sufficient to
do as well though it's not that question
as well the kinematics of the actual
little robot I mean these robots are
notoriously bad at having like correct
joint positions right so how much how
much hmm I guess did you run experiments
to see how much better your algorithm
gives this kind of like transfer to real
life versus just injecting random noise
to the motors because if you would take
random RAM random permutations of the
motors like how much better does your
simulator approximate that instead of
just like tweaking all of your little
motors continuously to try and inject
that kind of real-world problem into
that yeah today agent know it's a good
question so we did look at that baseline
as an approach and so I can what we did
gave ended up with like faster walking
performance I think the other
interesting like kind of trade-off you
see what those methods is that like by
like injecting noise you can learn more
robust policies so I guess going back to
the notion of local improvements of the
policy if you inject the noise like you
we could learn for longer and you can
still get like some stable policies that
would transfer to the robot but then you
kind of gave up some of the like
exploiting the real world so like not as
fast but still but still stable if it
makes yeah but I mean at the same time
like your algorithm that tries to
approximate the real world might have
some air and you're still translating
air to the robot
yeah no no yeah exactly I mean they're
still error I guess what yeah what we
saw like kind of empirically was that I
guess less error than just kind of
adding the way some into things so just
cool to see the result of so is that
like truly the documented
fastest vlog for that little guy so we
took I mean this is like I guess it's
mainly based on so the RoboCup
competitions or like there's like a lot
of people trying to get the the fastest
walk on these nails I mean we use this
in the the competition last year and
there weren't there weren't teams using
a faster walk than this as far as we
know like reported speeds it is as well
so I feel like that needs to be like the
subtask in the Nano competition yeah so
we've there is some I mean like there's
some work on like trying to get them to
go just like incredibly fast and you
don't care if the robot falls over that
so in that case that's not exactly what
we're trying to compare with here
because we're can't we want to get
something which is actually useful for
like the task of RoboCup so this is like
both fast and stable whereas you can't
get them to go faster if you're willing
to have your robot fall over like at the
end of its run or so but yeah
yeah
all right well that's time desire okay
[Applause]